my
okay thank you welcome to the rochefort
district council remote planning
committee meeting and welcome to anyone
watching this
via live stream going through the agenda
item number one is apologies for absence
and i believe that we have apologies
from councillors michael hoy
and simon wooden
agenda item number two substitute
members attending
councillor stuart wilson will be
substituting for councillor michael hoy
and councillor mrs laurie and shaw will
be substituting for council simon wooden
item number three is non-members
attending
sonia have you got anybody that will be
attending there are none
there are none thank you very much
agenda item number four
minutes the meeting held on the 20th of
january
2020 if it seems a long time ago now
our members uh in agreement with this
these minutes
thank you very much we're now moving on
to
item number five decorations of interest
would anybody indicate if they've got
any
declarations of interest to make
i can't see any okay
right we now move on to chairman uh
mrs mason uh is indicating sorry
yeah okay counselor mrs mason
thank you thank you chairman um this
isn't necessarily declaration of
interest but it's a statement i need to
make
i set aside last night to prepare for
this meeting
and i want to place on record that
despite the councils of being constantly
advised and being aware of the problems
i receive
that they have persisted consistently
persisted
in failing to provide documents that i
can access
i have done my best to prepare for this
meeting but in few of the council's
intelligence i will be finding it quite
difficult thank you
okay councillor mason mrs mason sorry i
i i believe sonia will take that on
board and uh
see if there's anything we can do for
for the future
um and i hope you feel better than you
actually
sound it's pardon
i hope you feel better than you actually
sound you sound like very croaky
i i have found this very difficult
yeah okay we'll move on to item number
six then which is the
essex coastal recreational disturbance
avoidance
a mitigation strategy in brackets that's
described as rams
supplementary planning document and that
is the
spd 2020 the presentation will be made
by mr daniel goodman team leader
strategic planning uh we'll be
introducing this report
we also have officers marcus hutton
and mrs yvonne dunn in attendance and
between the three of them hopefully they
should be able to answer any questions
or clarify any issues that you may wish
to raise
so i'll move over to you now mr goodman
thank you chair uh so this agenda item
uh relates to a supplementary planning
document that's been prepared
uh on behalf of the council um
it relates to a project that the council
has been engaged with
engaged in for around 18 months with
11 other local authorities across essex
and basically it's to put in place
a strategy to avoid and mitigate
the impacts of new housing on coastal
habitats
so it was something that natural england
raised as an issue through the
preparation of
of individual local plans and it has
kind of
necessitated a joint a joint solution
which is
uh which is the whole purpose of the
rams
so members will have previously seen the
final ram
strategy in april 2019
and late last year and early this
year the draft spd
was seen by council and recommended that
it goes out to public consultation
so this item is now reporting back on
the outcomes of that
public consultation and recommending
that
uh that the committee recommends to
council that it be adopted as part of
the council's planning documents um
so just as a quick overview on on the
purpose of the spd really
um so spds don't contain policies they
only contain guidance
but nevertheless they are useful in
terms of giving applicants
an understanding of of how policies will
be applied
um and the rams is is quite a a
difficult thing
to get your head around if if you're not
used to it so
clearly the the spd has been prepared
with the intention of
of of making that a simpler process for
people applying for
the planning permission for housing
development and the crux of
of the rams really is that every new
house built in the district
uh that's a net increase so not
replacements
uh has to provide a tariff of around 120
pounds
and those tariffs are pulled and then
will be used
to to provide that mitigation and that
mitigation
could be anything from human resource
so as we'll get on to there there is a
an ambition for there to be a
county-wide resource
um to physical things like signs
um advising people to keep their dogs on
their leads and things like that so it's
a real
it's real uh wide scale of of uh
of mitigation uh so just to quickly
summarize the outcomes of the spd
so uh the consultation rather
so uh there was a reasonable
response from 160 146 sorry
um individual comments
um and uh 12 of those were made by
residents of rochford
and quite a lot of others were made by
residents of of other essex authorities
the comments themselves um the the
changes that have been made based on
these comments are listed in
in the report to item six so i won't
read them all out but but fundamentally
most of them were just matters of detail
and clarity
making it clear uh how it would work and
addressing anything that
that respondents felt wasn't clear
fundamentally natural england are
supportive of this approach
um and uh and are supportive of councils
getting into getting in place an spd to
mean that the
the rams will be functionally uh
functioning effectively
uh so um i suppose just one last point
to make on this
on this item is that uh because it's a
legal responsibility of the council to
discharge the habitat regulations when
it comes to planning decisions
um failure to adopt the spd doesn't
actually change the council's
responsibilities in
in any way uh there's still a need to
implement the rams or or an alternative
but but it's clearly it's it's officers
views in recommending this item that the
the spd helps make uh make the whole
process much simpler for both the
council
uh and any applicants for planning
permission um
and um and hence
why uh the recommendation is that it
that it is recommended to council for
um for adoption uh so i'm happy to take
any
any questions on this item um
if you wouldn't mind uh letting me know
if anyone has their hand raised
okay members is that are there any
questions that uh you wish to
to raise with uh with daniel i think the
the most pertinent point is that
you know we do not discharge ourselves
of any legal responsibilities
if we don't take this situation on board
um i understand daniel the
sharing the responsibilities will also
share the financial costs
across the county um so really as
unless members have any other concerns
uh uh
i would suggest that we move on to uh
the recommendations that we fall to full
council in relation to this item
okay members well nobody seems to be
indicating that they have
uh any questions on this item we then
move on to
paragraph 10.1 on page 6.10
there are two recommendations to counsel
um can i ask if members are agreeable
that we take both of these items
together recommendations
one and two i will gladly read them out
if if that would
clarify the situation item number one
is that the essex coastal recreation
disturbance and avoidance and mitigation
strategy rams
supplementary planning document s e
d set out in appendix b be adopted
and item number two is that
you said we said report and adopted
statements set out in appendix a
and c respectively be published on the
council's website
our members in agreement with those two
being 40 to record to members
full council
i can't see anybody not indicating that
they're in agreement
right we will take that as being
accepted by members
and declare that motion has been carried
chairman uh we do we do need to do a
roll call
okay okay over to you son yeah
yeah um
so you're you're voting as to whether or
not you want a recorded vote
or voting for against abstaining on
recommendations one and two uh
councillor mrs lumley
no and agreed thank you
councillor mrs mason
councillor mrs mason mrs mason has her
hand raised on you
okay
it's okay i couldn't i
had trouble can you hear me
thank you counselor mrs shaw
no recording
thank you cancer sparing no recorded
vote and for the motion
counselor mrs weston
uh that's unanimously for chairman
thank you members we'll now move on to
agenda item number seven which is the
essex coastal recreation disturbance
avoidance and mitigation rams
partnership agreement
2022 to 2023 and again
daniel goodman the floor is yours
thank you chair uh so this item uh is
clearly
relates back to uh the previous item
so as i uh briefly mentioned the the
rams is a partnership approach across
um many local authorities in essex
um and it has been operating
successfully as a partnership so the
strategy itself has been developed
through the partnership
um and uh and the spd consultation and
all these things have been
um managed as a partnership so officers
have been attending
steering group meetings um and obviously
representing the council's interests at
those meetings
and uh this partnership agreement really
is to enshrine
a further kind of three-year program of
uh of partnership uh under the rams to
to actually move then
into more of the implementation phase um
so as i mentioned previously the main um
the main outcome of the rams is
uh is expected to be a per-dwelling
tariff of around 120 pounds
um and one of the main things that's
kind of
been raised through the rams really is
the fact that a lot of people
visit coastal habitats um outside of the
area they live
and therefore the impact of housing
built in one area actually
um is quite broad when it comes to to
impacting other areas and therefore
certainly natural england's view and the
view that's that's kind of shared by the
steering group is that actually
it's it's very ineffective both in terms
of
human resource and financial resource to
try to discharge the rams in
12 different chunks if you like across
the 12 different local authorities
um so this partnership agreement is
based on
uh on an offer if you like from
chelmsford city council to become
um the uh the accountable body for the
purposes of the rams for a period of
three years
and what that would mean in practice is
that the uh the the small amount of
human resource that this
project is expected to create out of the
tariffs
would be if you like managed by
chelmsford city council
but under clearly the direction of the
steering group making up all the
authorities
and the the the tariff contributions
collected by the local authorities will
be
um pulled um as part of the project
and then uh the steering group and other
um
other groups will determine how best to
spend
that money i suppose the the one thing i
would say on that
however is that clearly the rams is um
set up on an already identified package
of mitigation
therefore there is not going to be much
discretion if any
for decisions to be made exactly how to
spend the money
but clearly there are practical
decisions to be made
i.e you know if there's in principle
agreement that
signage is needed you know there's a
practical need to
determine you know how to procure that
signage where it's going to be placed
and things like that
um and so the partnership agreement um
aims to achieve all of that
and and the idea is very much that all
the authorities will be entering into it
for a period of three years
uh in terms of the council's um role in
it
i mean the view of offices in
recommending this item
is that the the amount of uh money that
the council will itself collect from the
rams
is likely to be insufficient to deliver
anything substantive
or at least it would have to be pulled
over such a significant period of time
that
that it ceases to become effective
mitigation
so our so our view on this very much is
that there there's a lot
of advantages in terms of operating this
as a partnership
and clearly the council will still have
a role to play in terms of
managing um how that's done um
and there are various um clauses if you
like set out in the partnership
agreement in terms of
um you know if the council was unhappy
with how the partnership was going it's
right of withdrawal and
and all those things um so
i suppose that's that's probably all all
i have to say on this item but
again i'm more than happy to take uh
take any questions on it
um as directed um by yourself chair
sorry chair i think you're muted
sorry thank you uh thanks daniel are
there any points members that uh
need clarification or wish to raise
right uh councillor mrs mason first of
all and then councillor wilson
council mrs mason yeah thank you
chairman um
i must admit uh like the principle of
the idea i like
the the fact that um chelsea are
overseeing it because i think they're a
very good authority
but the couple of bits i've picked up
that i'm quite concerned about
there seems to be an inconsistency in
the uh
allocation of charges um in one
paper i believe it said 10 and 5 and the
other it said 9.1 and 4.5
[Music]
i also question why two authorities have
a lower contribution also
the figures in 7.1 are not included
and the total costs are not included
there's no there's no real
um there's a sharing of costs in there
but there's no
indication of the overall cost
which is i set relatively minor points
that can be sorted but
the the major thing problem i have with
this
is the steering group
and the proposal that the steering group
is made up of offices i think if
something of this
importance to our council it should be
made up of members
with officer support and
that there's also seems to be no um
consideration of what would happen if we
became a combined authority to this
agreement there's no knowledge of that
so
those are points that i'd like clarified
do you want to go with those first of
all daniel and then we'll
move on to councillor wilson
yes that's yeah that's absolutely fine
um so in terms
of the uh i'll address the reason why
a couple of authorities are um being
asked to pay
slightly less the main reason for that
is that
the the way the rams has been managed is
on the basis of
um what have been called zones of
influence from the coastal habitat
sites and that's you know generally
trying to estimate how far the average
person would be likely to travel to
visit those habitat
sites but it just so happens that
brentwood and uttersford in particular
only an incredibly small part of their
authority area is actually
captured by one of these zones of
influence and clearly as they are
not coastal authorities i think the view
was taken in drafting this that
actually they are unlikely to receive
any of the benefit really from the
mitigation package and therefore whilst
there's a
legal requirement for them to be
involved um
the as a matter of fairness it seems
um unfair to ask them to contribute the
same as
as the coastal authorities so um
hopefully that hopefully that shines a
light on on on that issue
in terms of inconsistency with the with
the figures i mean i
i'll have to confess i'm not aware of of
of exactly what the inconsistencies are
although what i can say is that um
the council's being asked to fund
approximately three and a half thousand
pounds
per year a slightly lower figure in this
year given that we're already
significantly into this administrative
year um
and that's really just to cover the
aspects of the partnership that
could not be covered from the tariff and
that that might include things like um
kind of uh general administration around
recruiting staff and all those kind of
things
so so i am confident that three and a
half thousand pounds a year
um is the right figure um
if there are areas where that's
inconsistent then i apologize uh
and and the recommendation from um
offices on on that issue is that
actually it can be met from the existing
planning policy budget um which um
falls within the local development
framework reserve um
clearly if they're if those costs
changed markedly then
then certainly you know we would we
would reassess that and if necessary
um bring that as a discussion piece for
for for members
um in terms of the the member overview
i think um it i think it's a fair point
uh although the way that it's kind of
been um
been looked at in terms of this
partnership is that the decision making
for the steering group is likely to be
um
quite low level um
and therefore not big picture matters
and so given that the ram strategy
already identifies the mitigation
package
the amount of discretion that the
steering group made up of officers all
members could ever have
is quite limited and so the way that the
partnership has been
has been pitched if you like is that the
steering group will be officer led but
fundamentally it's for each
set of officers to have um
you know to to go back to their council
and seek whatever permission that they
might need
one of the recommendations for this item
um which obviously
i'm sure we can get on to is that
marcus as assistant director for this
service be
delegated authority in in consultation
with council award to
make decisions that are necessary to
discharge this partnership
and clearly if council award felt that
there was a need to to invite
the committee's view on on issues then
i'm sure that we could do that
i'm just conscious too of creating
a disproportionate burden um
on both members and officers in terms of
discharging kind of very low level
decisions so
um i apologize if there are any other
questions
included in that i'm more than happy to
answer them but um
hopefully that was all of all of the
questions
uh councilman mrs mason do you wish to
come back on that
yes it certainly covers the financial
aspects
i'm i'm not sure that i would call um
something like wallace the island a low
level um decision and
under the the coast our coastal
areas is a fast point of
amount of our area land area and i think
it's quite important that members are
involved
and i'm unhappy with the way this
is officer dominated i do think
members should be more involved and i do
think that that's
a flaw in this agreement and it's
it's the only clause that i say and but
you haven't answered the question
about what would happen if we became as
as anticipated at combined authority and
there's no
knowledge of that in the report
um well i suppose in all honesty that
question probably hasn't been raised and
that that may well be an oversight on
on our on our side i think
if i'm being honest in practical terms
you know my understanding limited
understanding possibly of
of the prospect of of local government
reorganization is that it will be years
in the making and i think
it's probably worth saying that this um
partnership agreement has
an end date of of 2023
um and each authority within the
partnership does have a right of
withdrawal
with six months notice therefore i i
imagine it would be quite simple for the
partnership to cease to
to be using the courses clauses within
the partnership agreement
um i take the point on board i'd be more
than happy to seek clarification from
other local authorities in the
partnership in advance of council
possibly
as to whether or not that needs
specifically addressing
um in the partnership agreement um
but but i would say i i think there are
sufficient clauses within the the
agreement itself to to to
protect any one council's um
situation um if that event did come to
be
um you know clearly the council could
decide at any time that it wishes to
serve notice to leave the partnership
and
and
if it knew it was it was on that path
then possibly that that would be a
course to take
thank you daniel that's really clarified
the
situation with rounded combined
authority which leaves the only
concern that i have is the lack of
member involvement i don't think it
should be
necessarily council reward i don't think
we should um impose it on
an assistant director who's obviously
very busy
and i think that the representation
should be member-led but apart from that
you've answered the questions thank you
councilor wilson before i come on to you
i think uh two officers uh
mrs dunn and marcus hotlin wish to
probably add some comment to
what daniel's just said so before we
move on to you council wilson
can uh evon would you like to to come in
and then then marcus
yeah i'm possibly going to say the same
as what marcus might
say but um what i would um just sort of
confirm
um what daniel said that you know
should should circumstances change with
um you know government structure um
you know but there are a number of
partnership agreements that will need to
be reviewed as a result of changes of
that nature
um and this would just be one of those
you know each authority will find
themselves in the same situation
and it will be a matter that we would
have to sort of you know revisit
other partnership agreements as well uh
to find a solution
um to how they would work going forward
so i just wanted to confirm that
thank you marcus do you wish to add
anything
no i think the point's been covered
thank you okay can i can i just ask dan
before we go on to
council wilson uh one who assumes that
there will be
routine reports coming to this committee
regarding uh any actions that are taken
in in
relation to this joint project
yes so there certainly can be i think
i've said in the report that
um that those reports could be could be
taken to council but it would seem to
make sense that they that they come here
um perhaps first or or instead
um i think just one thing i would
reiterate on that issue
really is um the the what the
partnership's likely to
to deliver if you like out of the
contributions is not going to be
transformational projects i think it's
fair to say clearly
i would be more than happy um if
uh if there was decisions to be made
about
um big ticket items if you like that
that have
a clear impact on the on the cat on the
district's interests you know
certainly we would we would take that um
to the committee or council and we would
certainly
seek member uh endorsement of that
decision
i think what i'd say is that the vast
majority of decisions are likely to be
far more around
how and where to procure signage and how
and where to
work you know to to to to maybe propose
slight
minor re-routing of paths and things
along those lines
um so we'd be more than happy to keep
members up to date from that and
and if they feel necessary you know
above a certain point
obviously to seek permission for that i
i suppose the reason why the steering
group is officer led in this
circumstance really
is just because um there may be a need
for
lots of very minor rapid decisions
that don't really have much of a
financial bearing but but nevertheless
need need to be made
and and i suppose that that's why it's
been pitched as it has really as an
officer-led steering group
that one that seeks um seeks endorsement
from members
when required but but certainly i mean
we can report into the committee
or council um you know on a quarterly or
six monthly basis if that works
on decisions that are due to be made
decisions that have been made and
progress
along those lines thank you i think that
might reassure members
along those lines thank you for your
patience councilor wilson over to you
sir
thank you very much it's really only for
my uh my own benefit
i know that we mentioned in the report
and daniel mentioned it about
um the operating across boundaries and
those are the sort of intro essex
boundaries are there any
are there any other circumstances where
we would liaise with people like ken
or consult with ken um because although
we haven't got a land boundary then
obviously there is a wildlife boundary
effectively
uh so so the short answer is is yes
um so for a pr from practical
perspective the way that natural england
has set up the rams is
is trying to use just distinct
boundaries where they can
um just to try and make it manageable
but certainly there is a rams project in
in kent
um there's a rams project in suffolk
there's rams projects
all over the place i know there's one in
the solent which was a bit of a pilot
so certainly when it comes to probably
suffolk and
um and ken um
there is a there is a need to have a
dialogue
i suppose because this is because this
is people
going from their house to the habitat
site
it's unlikely that a significant number
of people
jump over the dart for crossing to go
and visit
north kent to walk their dog for example
i think the issue is probably more
pronounced around the suffolk boundary
and certainly there's been a lot of
conversation with
with them where you've got you know
colchester tendering
um and authorities along those lines who
might reasonably walk their dogs or
exercise or um or whatever just over the
suffolk coast so
there is alignment there but but from
the perspective of collecting the rams
tariff and um implementing the rams
um we we have to work to some boundary
and that's why the county boundaries
have been drawn as they
as they have been but certainly um they
have attended steering group meetings in
the past to give updates on on their
projects and
and if there was an opportunity to align
then
then i have every expectation that it
that it will be aligned
you know there won't be a circumstance
where we're doing um
you know the opposite to one another in
on the same stretch of coastal path
you know i i don't think that would ever
happen
thank you anything else council wilson
no that's it thank you chairman
members are there any more questions
that you wish to raise with uh mr
goodman
bearing bearing in mind his comments
regarding uh either a quarterly or six
monthly update for this committee i
think would be more
appropriate um taking that in
as as an as an accepted uh
process with members
now consider voting on the
recommendations one two and three
together please
counsel mrs mason
just a question on clarity i mean
i know the finances involved are very
small
but sometimes small decisions have quite
large impacts and it's not the finances
that i'm concerned about it's the impact
on the
area i know the officer has said that
the they will decide when they need
member involvement but
what concerns me is how that decision is
made because we're still allowing
the officers to determine when members
are invited
advised so i do have concerns about the
um the steering group makeup but
having said that um we have very regular
reports
i suppose that will mitigate it to some
extent but i i remain
uncomfortable with the makeup of the
steering group thank you
i i accept your comments mrs mason but i
think uh
at the moment the best course of action
that we i would propose
is that we ask uh mr goodman to ensure
that we have a quarterly report
of any issues and that if there are
other areas that we need to attend to
urgently
that this is brought to us on an ad hoc
basis
and if necessary we will arrange a
meeting to discuss the situation
would that be more confident for you mrs
mason
i think yes it it helps but the
the onus is still with the officers and
not with the members and that's where i
have a concern
but obviously you know
i know this has happened in the past and
it has worked well but that doesn't mean
that we can't
change things and improve them so yes it
answers the question i accept that
probably um majority don't agree with
i still feel that there should be more
member involvement and
less reliance on officer determination
but that that's my opinion
and i accept that not everyone will
agree with that
thank you very much okay members um
taking account of mrs accounts mrs
mason's comments
um can we vote for these three
recommendations together
i will read them out to you again that
the council
enters into a partnership agreement
attached
at appendix a that the authority be
delegated to assistant director
place and environment to discharge the
council's responsibility
under the partnership agreement in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for planning
that it be agreed that the annual cost
of around three thousand five hundred
pound
be met from the existing local
development framework reserve
unless i see any hand icons i assume
that we will do a role call
on all three items
okay nobody nobody is indicated do you
want to do the
the roll call sonia so um
councillor mrs lumley please no
and i agree
councillor mrs mason
thank you thank you councillor mrs shaw
no and agree
cancer sparing
no and agreed
councillor mrs weston there's no one
agreed
chairman councillor
wilson no and agreed
that's uh five four and one abstention
chairman
thank you members i therefore declare
this motion has been carried
that concludes the meeting uh thank you
very much for attending
and i now declare this meeting closed at
10
36 thank you chairman bye everybody
thank you goodbye thank you